♪ ♪ ♪
- OK! You are going to show
themow you can slide laaa
big boy!
- En banlieue de Dallas, Candace
Valenzuela se bat pour un
meilleur avenir pour les siens.
Cette citoyennororororigines
latinos et afro-américaines
s'est présentée aux élections de
2020 sous les couleurs
démocrates. Elle a été défaite
de peu par la candidate
républicaine.
Tentera-t-elle à nouveau sa
chance en 2024? Seul problème,
sa résidence a été retirée du
comté où elle voulait se faire
élire.
- Tous les dix ans, le parti
au pouvoir dans l'État, c'est-à-
dire les républicains, peut
redessiner les cartes
électorales pour que chaque
district compte à peu près le
même nombre de résidents.
Mais, dans le cas de Candace, ce
redécoupage était très ciblé et
même avoué par une de ses
adversaires.
- Elle a été victime de ce qu'on
appelle ici, le gerrymandering,
un redécoupage des limites
des circonscriptions qui a fait
de son district, qui penchait
en faveur des démocrates,
un district maintenant
pro républicain.
- Ce charcutage électoral ne
date pas d'hier. En fait, il
faut remonter à 1811 lorsque
le gouverneur du Massachusetts,
Elbridge Gerry, avait été accusé
àavavavavavavavoir redessiné sa
circonscription afin de garantir
le succès de son parti aux
élections. Le redécoupage
électoral ressemblait en fait à
une salamandre.
Garry, Gerry, une salamandre,
on fait un mot-valise avec et
ça donne le gerrymandering.
C'est un concept très populaire
ici, au Texas, mais aussi en
Ohio, en Georgie et en Floride,
des États administrés par des
républicains mais aussi dans
l'Illinois, un terrain
démocrate.
ANTOINE YOSHINAKA, prof.
sciences pol. Université NY
-  C'est une grosse industrie en
fait le redécoupage de la carte
électorale, beaucoup plus aux
États-Unis qu'au Canada.
- Et c'est légal partout aux
États-Unis et forcément de bonne
guerre entre démocrates et
républicains.
- Les États n'ont pas, si vous
voulez, carte blanche pour
redessiner la carte électorale
de manière entièrement
partisane, mais ceci étant dit,
évidemment, qui dit constitution
américaine, qui dit lois
fédérales dit interprétation dee
constitution par les cours. Ça
reste, évidemment,
un processus évidemment très
partisan.
- Domingo Garcia est avocat et
acacacacacacacacac, la plus plus
grande organisation non
gouvernementale de défense des
droits civils des hispaniques
aux États-Unis.         à chaque
imposé par les républicains, son
organisation contre-attaque
- Alors, à chaque redécoupage
imposé par les républicains, son
organisation contre-attaque
devant les tribunaux.
- Sauf qu'entre les appels et
les décisions de la Cour
suprême, cela prend de trois à
cinq années avant que les cartes
électorales.s.s.s.s.s.s.s.s.s.
Aujourd'hui, Candace s'est
résignée, personnellement, mais
pas pour les minorités sous-
représentées.
- Car, ici, au Texas, la
population a beaucoup changé
avec une croissance
démographique des latinos.
- En 202ngngngngngngngngngngngte
d'États ont soumis leur nouveau
redécoupage de circonscriptions.
Et ce sont les Républicains qui,
au bout du compte global,devrais
lors de prochaines élections.
Tout cela inquiète Candace
Valenzuela.
- Face à tous ces obstacles,
croire encore en la démocratie
américaine est devenu, pour
certains ici, une véritable
profession de foi.